have this reaction here where if I had a
mole of methane and I react that with
two moles of oxygen I'll produce the
mole of carbon dioxide and two moles of
water but we want to answer in this
video is whether this reaction is
spontaneous and we learned in the last
video that to answer that question we
have to turn to Gibbs free energy or the
change in Gibbs free energy and the
change in Gibbs free energy is equal to
the enthalpy change for the reaction
minus the temperature which it is
occurring times the change in entropy
and if this is less than zero then it's
a spontaneous reaction spontaneous so I
got us a I gave us a little bit of a
head start I just calculated the change
in enthalpy for this reaction and that's
right here and we know how to do that
we've done that several videos ago it
you could just look up the heats of
formation of each of these products it
for water you'll multiply it by two
since you have two moles of it and so
you have the heats of formation of all
the products and then you subtract out
the heats of formation of all the
reactants and of course the heat of
formation of o2 is 0 so this won't even
show up in it and you'll get minus 890
point 3 kilojoules what's tells us that
this is an exothermic reaction that this
side of the equation has less energy in
it you can kind of think of it that way
is that side so some energy must have
been released we could even put here you
know plus e for energy let me write plus
some energy is going to be released so
that's why it's exothermic but our
question is is this spontaneous so to
figure out if it's spontaneous we also
have to figure out our Delta s our Delta
s and to help figure out the Delta s I
head of time looked up the standard
molar entropy s for each of these
molecules so for example the standard
I'll write it here in a different color
the standard and this is just the
notation the standard no there's no
Delta there let me erase I could just
write it here the standard standard and
standard you put a little knot symbol
there the standard molar entropy so when
we say standard it's at 298 degrees
Kelvin actually I shouldn't say degrees
Kelvin is at 290
Kelvin you don't use the word degrees
necessarily when you talk about Kelvin
so set 298 Kelvin which is 25 degrees
Celsius so at room temperature so that's
why it's considered standard temperature
so the standard entropy of methane at
room temperature is equal to this number
right here 186 joules per Kelvin molar
not molar per Kelvin mole so if I have
one mole of methane I have a 186 joules
per Kelvin of entropy if I have 2 moles
I multiply that by 2 if I have 3 moles
I've multiplied with that by 3 so our
total entropy is the entropy or the
total change in entropy of this reaction
is the total standard entropies of the
products minus the total standard
enterpise of the reactions just like
what we did with enthalpy so that's
going to be equal to 213 0.6 plus I have
2 moles of water here so it's plus 2
times 2 times let's just write 70 there
69 point nine almost 70 plus two times
70 and then I want to subtract out the
entropy of the reaction or this side of
the the reactants or the side of the
reaction so the entropy of one mole of
ch4 is 186 186 plus 2 times 205 2 times
205 so just eyeballing already this
number is close to this number but this
number is much larger than this number
liquid water has a much lower this is
liquid waters entropy it has a much
lower entropy than oxygen gas and that
makes sense because liquid form there's
a lot fewer states it kind of takes the
shape of it it you know it all falls to
the bottom of the container as opposed
to kind of taking the shape of the room
and expanding so a gas is naturally
going to have much higher entropy than a
liquid so just eyeballing it we can we
can already see that our products are
going to have a lower entropy than our
reactants so this is probably to be a
negative number but let's let's confirm
that let's confirm that so I have 200
let me see I have 200 to 13.6
plus well plus 140 right two times
seventy plus 140 is equal to 350 three
point six so this is three fifty three
point six and then from that I'm going
to subtract out so 186 plus two times
now let me see plus 2 times 205 is equal
to five 96 so minus 596 and what is that
equal to so let me put the minus five
ninety six and then plus the 350 350 3.6
and we have minus two hundred forty two
point four so this is equal to minus two
forty-two point four joules per Kelvin
is our Delta s minus two so we lose that
much entropy those units might not make
sense to you right now and actually
these are a bit of arbitrary units but
you can just say hey this is getting
more ordered and it makes sense because
we have a ton of gas we have three and
we have three separate molecules one
here and two molecules of water of
oxygen and then we go to three molecules
again but the water is now liquid so it
makes sense to me that we lose entropy
there's there are fewer states that the
liquid especially can take on but let's
figure out whether this reaction is
spontaneous so our Delta G Delta G is
equal to our Delta H we're releasing
energy so it's minus 890 I'll just get
rid of the decimals we don't have to be
that precise minus our temperature where
we're assuming that we're at room
temperature 298 degrees Kelvin that's 28
I should just say 298 Kelvin I should
get in the habit of not saying degrees
when I say Kelvin which is 25 degrees
Celsius times times our change in
entropy now this is going to be minus
now you might say okay - 240 - you might
want to put that there we have to be
very very very careful this right here
is in kilojoules this right here is in
joules so we want to write if we want to
write everything in kilojoules since we
already wrote that down
let's write this in kilojoules so it's
point two for two kilojoules kilojoules
per Kelvin so I can put a point two for
two let me get rid of this right there
kilojoules per Kelvin and so now our
Gibbs free energy right here is going to
be minus 890 kilojoules minus 209 so the
minus and the minus you get a plus and
that makes sense that this the entropy
term is going to make our Gibbs free
energy more positive which as we know
since we want to get a we want to get
this thing below zero this is going to
fight the spontaneity but let's see if
it can overwhelm if it can overwhelm the
actual enthalpy the exothermic nature of
it and it seems like it will because you
multiplied a fraction times this it's
going to be a smaller number than that
but let's just figure it out so divided
by one two three that's our change in
entropy times 298 that's our temperature
is minus 72 so this so this term becomes
and then we put a minus there so it's
plus 72 point two so this is the entropy
term at standard temperature it turns
into that and this is our enthalpy term
so we can already see that the enthalpy
is a much more negative number than our
positive term from our temperature times
our change in entropy so this term is
going to win out this term is going to
win out even though we lose entropy in
this reaction it releases so much energy
that's going to be spontaneous this is
definitely less than zero so this is
going to be a spontaneous reaction as
you can see these Gibbs free energy
problems are really not too difficult
you just really need to find these
values and to find these values you
it'll either be given the Delta H but we
know how to solve for the Delta H you
just look up the heats of formations of
all the products subtract out the
reactants and of course you wait by the
number by the coefficients and then to
figure out the change in entropy you do
the same thing you have to look up the
standard molar entropy of the products
weight by the coefficients subtract out
the reactants and then just substitute
in here and then you essentially have
the Gibbs free energy and
case it was negative now you could
imagine a situation where with a much
higher temperature let's wear it like
we're at the surface of the Sun or
something where all of a sudden instead
of a 298 here if you had like a I don't
know you had a two thousand or a four
thousand there then all of a sudden
things become interesting if you know I
mean if you could imagine if you had a a
forty thousand Kelvin temperature here
then all of a sudden the entropy term
the loss of entropy is going to matter a
lot more and so this term this positive
term is going to outweigh this and maybe
it wouldn't be spontaneous at a very
very very very high temperature another
way to think about it a reaction that
generates heat that lets out heat
doesn't matter that the heat being
released doesn't matter so much when
there's already a lot of heat or kinetic
energy in the environments if the
temperature was high enough this
reaction might would not be spontaneous
because maybe then the entropy term
would win out but anyway I just wanted
to do this calculation for you to show
you that you know there's nothing to
abstract here you can look up everything
on the web and then figure out if
something is going to be spontaneous